hey youtubers is Charlie hopefully
you've had a chance to see the Doctor
Who finale I feel like there gonna be a
lot of opinions a lot of stuff to talk
about we even saw some footage from the
Christmas special so I'm gonna do a
breakdown of that to a bunch of you have
already been asking me on Twitter about
some of the big moments and what they
imply about next year in series 9 so I
will address all those but I will be
doing a separate series 9 predictions
video later this week real quick
reminder the weekly giveaway regenerates
this week so all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video but careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen it yet starting with
top 10 moments number 10 dr. Oswald lots
of doctor Clara lying totally explained
the Clara never existed line that we got
from the trailer that was definitely a
little bit misleading part of me is just
a little disappointed that it didn't
turn out to be some grand master plot I
felt like they kind of dropped that the
last couple of episodes they'd been
teasing that Missy had placed Clara in
the doctors path and I feel like that
really didn't end up going anywhere but
since they're making the transition to a
new companion between now and series 9 I
understand why they didn't get too crazy
with it so Danny pink Clara felt very
disconnected from Missy by the end of
this episode number 9 no one seems to
give a about all the Cybermen this
might be some social commentary from
Moffat about how no one is scared about
anything anymore I mean the children
didn't care about the forest they were
completely unimpressed
maybe that's why everyone's just taking
selfies with the Cybermen or maybe he's
just making fun of people that take
selfies all the time number 8 unit is
back so many awesome things here Osgood
with the bowtie Kate Stewart with the
Mondas Cybermen head that also might
explain why people are totally
unimpressed with the Cybermen it might
be a little Easter Egg for the second
doctor episode the invasion the whole
st. Paul's Cathedral Cybermen marching
down the steps thing was just a callback
to that I was kind of hoping that that
Cybermen head would turn out to be
handles they still haven't explained
where handles came from it's still out
there he could still use that in series
9 of all the things that Moffat is
famous for its turning really small
things into really big things
number 7 though Cyberman raining
everywhere so when Missy explained they
were pollinating the cyber conversion
process goes like this
Cyberman explodes in the air spreading a
giant cloud of nanites nanites bond with
water molecules in the air rain down and
start cyber converting organic matter
they were only converting
the dead because they needed empty
vessels to fill with the minds that she
could control that's why I jumped to the
shot of the chaplet funeral home which I
believe is a reference to dodo chaplet
who was a companion towards the end of
the first doctor's run the critical step
though is Missy downloading all the
stored minds from the data cloud into
the cyber converted bodies if she didn't
do that
it'd just be a bunch of lifeless
Cybermen number six dr. president of
Earth I feel like they cram more
references to classic who in this scene
than almost anywhere else in the episode
there's the Brigadier painting the fact
that the fourth doctor was president of
the Time Lords for brief period which I
think happened during a master arc I
heard a Thunderbird shout out and then
there was the bit about the doctor never
saluting the Brigadier which they did
pay off at the end
number 5 Missy finally references
Gallifrey as expected
Gallifrey was mentioned I would have
been pretty pissed that they hadn't
Missy's comment leaves a lot to be
desired
the way it's written just leaves a lot
of room for interpretation she kind of
waves her hand to the mechanics of how
she survived the 50th here's what I
gathered the doctors save Gallifrey
during the 50th so all the events of end
of time were nullified everyone
including Rassilon were incorporated
into the new Capaldi timeline right off
the bat I have two theories about how
she got out of the pocket universe we
know she has a TARDIS which I think is
that red phone booth that we keep seeing
in the background she could have found a
way to pilot it out of the pocket
universe that the other Time Lords just
haven't discovered yet she just be a
little bit more clever than them or
option number two
climbing out of the painting during the
50th those are just a couple theories
about how she escaped so if you have a
different one just write up below in the
comments number 4
Missy bails on the plane and leaves the
doctor hanging midair I love that she
was just waiting for him to go splat and
regenerate there were a lot of comments
about what was going on with Missy's
regenerations and the doctors
regenerations
even though there was a whole matrix
vibe coming off last week and that was a
classic story involving someone trying
to steal the doctors regenerations
I didn't think Moffat was gonna go that
way with Missy I feel like he was
presenting her as like a brand new cycle
kinda like Capaldi and a lot of you
hypothesized in the comments that Missy
somewhere around her fourth regeneration
maybe neither of them are super worried
about running out of her generations or
dying
the midair doctor TARDIS saved was a bit
exciting yes
Seb going squee
was a little bit much so I was totally
not surprised whenever Missy vaporized
them really bummed that Osgood had to
die for all this to go down I really
loved her character and even though they
saved Kate I do think that Osgood is
gone I think they just didn't want to
use the character again so they killed
her off or they didn't think the actors
was gonna come back they did give her a
nice exit I mean Missy gave her all
those nice compliments called her pretty
tried to boost her self-esteem before
vaporizing her I don't think of Osgood
as a companion but I do feel like they
gave her as close to a big companion
exit as you could give a character that
wasn't actually a companion number three
Danny pink Cyberman feels appropriately
horrific reveal when he pulled that face
mask off I feel like we knew it was
gonna be him the minute we saw that
crumpled up paper earlier in the episode
who else was thinking of Dalek Oswin at
the end of asylum like when we saw the
human face inside the Dalek I do feel
like that moment is just a level of
scary that series eight never quite got
up to Dalek Oswin way more frightening
to watch the in Cyberman Danny pink
totally not surprised the Danny pink had
a level of control over the other
Cybermen although I feel like the doctor
could have done the exact same thing
when he had that control bracelet he
could have exploded them all on the sky
couple of really awesome graveyard
favorites including gravestones for Amy
Rory and Victorian Clara there had been
a rumor of an Amy Rory Cyberman seen and
I'm actually kind of glad that it wasn't
in there I feel like it would have been
just way too much with them already
doing all the Brigadier Cyberman stuff
number two the master explains
everything I just want my friend back
best reason to destroy the human race
ever so we just have to spend some time
talking about Michelle Gomez in this
episode she did an amazing job of being
sympathetic I really feel like her
version of the master just desperately
wants their best friend back but because
the sound of drums she's completely
insane which apparently carries over
from regeneration to regeneration think
about it this way though she did not
care about what the Council of Time
Lords was gonna do to them
whenever they got back to Gallifrey
that's how bad she wanted the doctor
back Michelle Gomez wins this episode
always you win I really do think she's
amazing and I can't wait to see how
Moffitt explains her surviving this
episode the next time she shows up yes I
definitely think she's coming back at
some point maybe not the Christmas
special but hopefully at some point
during series 9
I feel like she'll just continue to be
tied to the Gallifrey plot regardless of
whatever the next big scheme is just
address the coordinates that she gave to
the doctor
I feel like Gallifrey is out there it's
still totally fine in the pocket
universe
she just omitted some critical piece of
information either that or the doctor
was just being a pudding brain and
misinterpreted what she said my number
one WTF moment Clara leaves and we get
Christmas special footage so let's start
with Clara I totally understand the
Danny pink and credit scene I understand
why they wrote it that way they just
wanted to give his character a sad but
really hopeful ending I think the reason
that they didn't have Clara
jump into that void was just because
they didn't want to repeat the Amy Pond
scene from serious 7 plus they needed
her for that scene in the cafe to lay
the groundwork for a new companion to
come in that could go down in the
Christmas special or they could save it
for like the first episode of series 9 I
like that they slipped in another female
doctor joke with the Queen reference I
do think that we will totally see a
female doctor in our lifetime I just
don't think that it's gonna happen in
the next couple of regenerations after
that we can reconsider it's just a
little premature to predict on when
we'll see a female doctor Moffat has not
confirmed series 10 yet but I do think
he's coming back for series 9 it's just
because I think series 9 is gonna
premiere about the same time the series
8 premiered and in order to do that
they'd have to start filming episodes
really early in the year which means
they'd have to finish scripts to start
shooting those episodes by the end of
this year Moffat is a really busy man I
mean they're shooting the Sherlock 2015
Christmas special in January so I think
after they're done with that they'll
start shooting series 9 so now just
address the Christmas special footage
yes that was Nick Frost a Santa Claus in
the teaser image that they released of
him a couple weeks ago he was wearing a
futuristic Luca uniform so either he's a
humanoid alien playing Santa or is gonna
be from Earth's future playing Santa
Christmas episodes always deal with
Christmas as an event so I think that
explains the Santa suit but I've seen a
lot of you theorized that the episode is
gonna present Santa Claus as a real
person like he exists he's not just a
character that other people dress up as
the locations gonna be a research
station at the North Pole whatever the
doctor said that I just thought of Ice
Station zebra which is a cold war movie
from the 60s the creature looks like it
could be a nice warrior without the
armor sometimes they spoil things like
that in the promo so the
release more clips and images in the
next couple of weeks we've only got
seven before it actually airs so just
expect new things from the BBC once a
week so now the real question is is how
does this finale stack up against all
the other finales at least the recent
ones just to try to be a little more
objective about it I'm only gonna rank
this finale against the other doctor's
first finale so that's like series five
series two series one I think that when
an actor who plays the doctor gets more
seasons you just have more time to bond
with them so whenever they have like
their second or third finale it just
ends up being more rewarding so it's
kind of unfair to compare Capaldi's
first finale against David Tennant's
third finale first off I think
Eccleston's
finale is still the best the series 1
then the series 5 finale then series 2
then death in heaven so I don't think
the death and haven't quite nailed the
dismount
but I still love it for bringing back
the master in a really interesting way I
mean I gave it a solid b-plus I just I
feel like it had too much extra baggage
to deal with it was trying to do too
many things you have a brand new doctor
trying to wrap up his first big arc his
companion has to leave so they have to
transition between one companion and the
next and they have a gender swapped fan
favorite character being reintroduced so
in all fairness a lot of this was out of
the BBC's control originally Matt Smith
was supposed to stay on for series 8
changed his mind early last year so they
had to scramble to find a new doctor
that by itself created a whole lot of
interesting problems but they did find
Peter Capaldi who's amazing but that
also creates a lot of issues for car as
a companion so you didn't have a whole
lot of time for her to bond with Matt
Smith like Amy Pond got new doctor comes
in so there's a whole new relationship
that they have to set up and then she
leaves right at the end of the first
season of that so it's just a little bit
messy there with companions coming and
going really frequently but all in all I
am very excited for the Christmas
special and for what series 9 has in
store like I said I'll be posting a
series 9 predictions video later this
week so be sure to subscribe to get it
my Q&A will post tomorrow so be sure to
ask all your finale
Gallifrey Christmas special questions
right now you can click here to get that
I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post it and you can click here for my
episode 11 video thank you so much for
watching so let's all high-five and I
will see you guys tonight
you